whenever you face a setback or things
don't go the way you have planned there
is absolutely no reason to get
discouraged let's say you worked hard on
a project but you eventually failed your
failure depends on various reasons but
that doesn't mean that the system of
working hard actually failed while
working hard on hard problems you train
your memory muscle and you improve your
analytical thinking which results in
overall better problem solving ability
eventually you will succeed on a similar
project and the overall working system
improves systems thinking can help us
see that quote unquote failing systems
are essentially a way to evolve our
thinking patterns